I think I was like three and I remember
seeing the head of a pig in a trash can
and that's how you know you're Cuban the
24th is the big day traditionally we
celebrate nor Joanna and then the food
is like the main dish or the main
attraction really when it comes to
Christmas time that's kind of when we
bust out the tamales what we do for our
holidays is that sometimes we do have
either a turkey or we have chickens or
we have tamales but what's all these are
kind of famous for now is fine come favo
or bank-owned gallo-roman Isola I was
born in Caracas the piece de resistance
is usually the van de jamon and the a
jackass but the pan de jamon is like
super super popular because you pretty
much eat it with everything the amount
of time then it takes to make these done
my list is like a lot so you do it kind
of like a week maybe two weeks in
advance and you make you make like 500
on my list and that takes a lot a lot of
work
thank you filled with GC mass transit
the low guys for mucho is Demi Corazon
so I present to you be another poetical
season with onions and garlic so aside
from the pork we would have like always
a rockin Frijole
Plata Nieto frito tostones the infamous
caja China why it's called that I have
no idea so this is a typical dish that
is serving Colombia during Christmas
it's actually two things it's buñuelos
and then the other thing is not the yeah
I think it originated in Spain but it's
super popular in Colombia I brought we
call it hell pico de Franco so um it's
basically chicken salad and yeah in
Brazil and in Colombia and in South
America it's summer during the holiday
it's actually pretty hot looks delicious
my mouth just watered looking at it mmm
salud
how would you that's it mmm this is
perfect no just so good we can't go
wrong with that it looks like heavy but
it's not it's super light it's cold it
works fast right here Latinos like me
she's delicious
I really like this this packs a punch of
flavor down in Miami near the Caribbean
we'd a lot of banana we don't do much of
the corn things this is nice
oh my god yeah that's all
is gonna be the bomb it's like meaty
like sauce for meat I'm not really big
fan of Olives but this is maybe the
first time that I've ever actually
enjoyed all of it something are there
radishes in here yeah we are radishes in
cucumbers for the crunch I love
Christmas I love it's like the best you
got the best food everybody in the world
has beautiful dishes that they should
share Latinos there's so many of us
there's so many countries and we don't
really get to taste each other's food
often so funny cuz like our countries
are bordering each other I think the
most precious valuable thing about this
is the tradition food is the way to
communicate with each other that's the
way humans do um so by eating each
other's food you can probably get a
little bit of their culture or a little
bit more understanding of their culture
yeah that's an awesome thing